euer lieblings youtuber des vertrauens
laser zum luca hat natürlich mal wieder
absolut gar keine kosten und mühen
gescheut um euch den professionellsten
und unterhaltsamsten content in ganz
youtube deutschland zu liefern denn wie
reagieren heute gemeinsam auf verbotene
und akzeptierte deutsche vornamen
also wenn das keine innovationspreis ist
sondern als er ordne ich glaube war
allerdings gar nicht mehr darum heißen
brei herum meiner lieben freunde und
fangen direkt an mit dem ersten vornamen
den eltern wirklich ihrem kind geben
wollten was dann allerdings nicht
erlaubt wurde gucci
umzudenken den schmerzenden jürgens sohn
henry henry sonne bruder von
superman kanada warum das verboten wurde
er wird schwierig wenn man etwas
supermänner essen würde tomtom wenn man
das kind nach im navigationssystem in
meckenheim libro
ich weine viel talk welche eltern hätte
denken sicher das kind sieht aus wie
nelken heini micra movie
ich weiß es die lehrer bei meinem namen
schon oft probleme
da will ich locker genannt oder lucia
ich glaube dabei würden die recht
komplexe kriegen lord
ich meine
das sind zweiter haben einfach den namen
nehmen würdest du dann hätte man den
vornamen lord was genauso wie
wahrscheinlich prinz oder irgendwie so
darf man nicht oder könig oder kanzler
oder keine ahnung was schröder verstehe
ich nicht
warum können also das hat ja gar keinen
es ist ja eigentlich völlig in ordnung
der name wald meist daher gott
ich weiß aber auch nicht warum leute das
sich denken dass das passen würde zu
einem kind verleihnix
egal
verleihen besser nichts einfach so als
vorname sonne und da bin ich ganz
ehrlich versteh's nicht so ganz weil zum
beispiel die tochter von kyle jeffers
tommy also auf deutsch übersetzt
stürmisch und warum ist es dann in
amerika erlaubt aber in deutschland hast
du dann nicht nach irgendwelchen sachen
aber in enstone
brauchen wir zu denken steigenden hätte
wiederum was macdonald ist auch da
warum
denken die dann schon daran dass das
kind dadurch später gemobbt werden
könnte um unterhalt das kind zu schützen
oder was ist der hintergrund warum sowas
verboten dass satan
bedeutet teufel
kann man es halten nur nachvollziehen
atom fried egal
wie hat euch verarscht junge
hier spiegelt die gal
das wirklich elternteile dachten ja du
hast jetzt bierstüberl whiskey pro ich
verstehe halt die seite der eltern
überhaupt nicht dass man das überhaupt
gefragt hat beim macht man das beim
standesamt oder beim bernburger meldeamt
oder bürgerhaus wie heist doch kratos
also entweder verstehe ich die eltern
hätte gar nicht wie so was wirklich
erwägen als kindes name aber ich
verstehe ich auch häufig nicht warum
dann anderen namen nicht zugelassen so
was wie schröder oder so das ergibt
keinen sinn huma
ich meine hammer klingt ja eigentlich
ganz nah jah
welchen namen findet ihr von jungen
mädchen am besten
jeder hat ja eigentlich seine favoriten
schweiz worten die kommentare ich bin
schon was luca ist
einfach kuppe
das kann irgendwo nachvollziehen judas
ja okay wenn man sein kind so mäßig
verräter in die richtung dann taucht
also kommt aus der bibel ich lese
aktuell die bibel
wenn man sein
grammophon ich weiß nicht was ein
grammophon ist ich hab aber abbrechen
kann man ganz kurz eben google programm
no und es ist tatsächlich ein
das ist ein gerät zur aufzeichnung von
tönen wie
lula ist auch verboten ich weiß nicht
was das sein soll klingt eigentlich für
mich wie ein russischer vorname bei
julia oder irgendwie so also ich weiß
warum sitzen deutschen verboten das was
ich allerdings auch nicht so ganz
verstehen kann dass olga soll es gibt
doch sogar diese serie nils holgersson
rosenherz bruder habe ich ziemlich
abstoßend an atos und das heißt auf
altgriechisch tot in dem sinne kann man
verstehen wohl thanatos auch irgendwie
so ein griechischer vorname sein könnte
abfahrt ist für mich wie ein türkischer
frauen namen rieter keine ahnung warum
das um deutschen verbotenes als
zweitlinien checke ich auch gar nicht
hält sich an wie ein ganz normaler
jungen haben wir uns allerdings auch
schon zum letzten verbotenen namen in
der deutschen sprache und zwar mac war
nicu
weg waren miku weg war nicu
klingt wie so ein charakter von winnie
puh ich habe es euch allerdings zu
beginn des videos schon gesagt weil der
liebe freunde wir schauen uns heute
nicht nur verbotene vornamen der
deutschen sprache an sondern ich liebe
das damit die brille
immer so wenig runter rutscht müssen so
ich bin schlau oder perfekt wir schauen
uns heute auf jeden fall auch
tatsächlich dann schlussendlich
akzeptierte und erlaubte deutsche
vornamen an und fangen mit dem ersten
buch
bin ich auch nicht schlimm bücherei das
habe ich noch nie gehört
dann einfach blatt muss sie
wenn ich euch so verkehrt also wenn sie
irgendwie nuss trek heißen würde oder
werde so der spitzname war okay aber so
als vorjahr man sich da wäre ich ein
bisschen doch er vielleicht so ein
bisschen auf der kippe leonardo da vinci
franz
die deutschen champagner
mitgeschrieben irgendwie aber vielleicht
habe sich deswegen aber gerade so
gedacht oh dann kommt vielleicht durch
wenn sich mit ehe am ende ist ja
offensichtlich falsch geschrieben oder
die waren echt blöd und wissen nicht wie
vorgeschrieben wird da kann ich noch so
eine
maschine
aber wie kommt ihr auf so ein
schwachsinn hat sein okay
real-tor kisten sneakers sieben sternen
haye
gab sich irgendwas aus seiner serie mal
was sie bestellen hieß den sekunden
später das ist eine pflanzenart
hier
allerdings sieben blätter hat mett igel
der
prestige pro
einfach of duty gespielt cinderella
melodie das klingt einfach so als wenn
jemand im briefing punkt hätte und dann
läuft das sind rund dann suchte er so ja
okay wie geht nochmal dieses lied das
sind sie doch nicht als vorname für
deine tochter dann dementsprechend
propos ist einfach erlaubt
dass du dein kind pro polenz hätte sie
carola ist erlaubt
man wollte ich mich grafiken
die
dj
ich bin raus und von daher will ich ja
der stellt das heutige video zu beenden
wenn freunde abonniert einen kanal wenn
es euch gefallen hat hat sie nicht